hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots there's a new tomorrow I haven't
seen this there's a new tomorrow's
teachings coming up on tomorrow's
teachings really crazy that that
happened no fat girl will ever be
loved these videos are ridiculous he's
right though she she's teaching a good
lesson throw it up you're diry sled
what I have no idea what this video is I
have no idea what I'm about to watch
here oh my God who made this
food I did so you get invited to a
dinner party obviously you know one of
these two made it why would you say
that well this is the most amazingest
food I've ever had amazing most
the most
amazingness seriously Tom why do you
have to be such a weirdo what I'm just
giving my compliments to the chef great
job
Chef why thank you but the acting in
these are it's really good I know it's
like the kind of acting where you're
like were you guys you guys even in the
same room yeah you know they really do
sound so I'm was saying that chat they
sound like a Bethesda NPC's just talking
to each other for real how about some
foundation for old uh over here naive
tell us
everything okay it was it was the most
magical day of my entire life wait a
second an interracial relationship
[__]
leave it was just a regular day and I
decided to go to the mall because I
couldn't get a hold of Tom so I went cuz
it's Boost Mobile ran out of money you
know how that goes yada y y minutes I
know I know it's a weird strange thing
to even talk about minutes in 2023 but
his phone has minutes still has minutes
and it flips
I'm having some ice cream maybe you
should have less ice cream I actually
want some ice cream I want I want a
blizzard and I got that favorite flavor
that I like you know chocolate that you
won't say for some reason my favorite
flavor I got that favorite thing I like
I was walking around and I was shopping
and I was eating my ice cream and I
turned this corner and down on his knee
with these beautiful puppy dog eyes was
T he was making white people kiss his
boots cuz he was like really into their
he's they're the real Israelis
wait he was following you while you were
getting ice cream yeah and like stalking
you and setting up a uhhuh okay that's
weird staring at
me how could I say no also why is this
middle-aged woman with this acne guy
like 16-year-old kid like what are they
friends how about we get out of here and
you know tear up the bedroom a little
bit
um
no
Tom
Kayla what oh see what are you doing
here he's probably on his he's probably
on his Bluetooth
oh uh uh well you marry
me good
St it was it was just amazing like yeah
but what about like the 30-year age
difference I don't know how he knew
exactly where I was going to be at that
exact moment we both have an apple phone
and you're on a family plan yeah it's
pretty easy track my device click on the
other device magic or
something wow that's incredible again
can we talk about this [__]
middle-aged woman with this clearly liid
appears to be a college student yeah
what's going on how are they friends
this looks like a mil porn it does back
in our day one I would watch but still
it's every single age ranges in this
video every demographic is covered go
crazy at the parties it's an absolute
stud getting all the girls yeah it's
like it's like a mystery it's like a
mystery porn roulette it's like is this
a mil young boy porn is this interracial
lesbian what's happening who's leaving
who's staying I don't know it's like the
button but with porno yes yeah out
drinking everyone out partying everyone
jealous much oh no I can
never bro I'm incapable of jealousy wait
we're supposed to believe that these two
were roommates even though there's a big
age difference between them as well yeah
they were they were partying in
college where one of them was a drug
dealer he didn't go to the school can I
guess which
one was waiting for us
downstairs why can't it just be us to
are you gay or something it's the proper
that is that would be the thing I would
say what are you gay what are you gay
why ISS there's going be one chick there
for each of us called not being gay
mhm no you're the gay one hey he hey
you're both
gay bro I literally have girls waiting
for us downstairs are you coming or not
no I'm not going AC ready
no sorry for yelling love you you didn't
yell love
you jack knows how to throw some good
college parties why did you say I love
you to your
roommate cuz he's gay what's happening
in this one everyone's gay everybody gay
well the reason we wanted to to have you
guys over was that I'm really young and
I got lip fillers and it's super [__]
weird and her cheeks she got the cheeks
done too yeah we want to announce bro
she looks like one of those characters
from Lazy Town
yeah oh my God yeah we are having a baby
oh my god well let me finish for Dave
ruin he wants another one yeah he's said
number three is coming
yeah a so excited for you
congratulations hey question why do they
always want to buy boys Dave ruin came
with a with a Jamba Juice cup mixed with
both of their sperm and said just squirt
it in there and see what happens let's
see what happens you I don't know I
guess I bet it's probably for the same
reason that tranes never read to the
elderly yeah that's a good point it's
only kids so grateful to have you guys
in my life I've never had this kind of
support growing up an old lady and a
weird black guy I'm what support do you
need I always wanted love but I never
received it I had a hard time getting
over what my family did to me what are
you doing you need those chips um I'm
hungry didn't you just eat lunch yes
then why are you eating cuz I'm still
hung hold on I just want to point
something out cuz I love this one of my
favorite things to do in
these the Airbnb no smoking
sign yes good catch the Airbnb oh look
to the right too to the right there's
the code for there's the code for the
thing that's the Wi-Fi password for the
airpnp eating cuz I'm still hungry
you're fat give me those also can I
point something out I I love that we
flash back to her childhood to a
completely upto-date modern Place MH
with with a current generation of
Cheetos current generation of Cheetos
those blinds were not very popular 20
years they no fat girl will ever be
loved that's a fact though that's true
though up it's okay we're here for you
thank you fat girl fatty by the way can
I put something out look at the wall
same Airbnb oh my God they're just in a
different section of it it dude it's
smart if you think about it if you're
going to crank this video out cheap true
two different are of the house cuz who's
going to tell
yeah I love you guys love you babe
you're like 15 and she's like 30 what's
happening all of this is so weird I can
relate what happened
growing up I had a problem with my
stepdad uh-oh it's okay babe he made me
gay what are you
gay what are you doing here boy I just
kidding you know why they had to say
stepdad because they had a white actor
for this they're going to get two black
actors wait for the voice over all right
wait for the voice okay I heard I heard
it I heard it let's
go it's okay
babe
what are you doing here boy I just
getting a drink of
water boy I swear to God I thought that
was I thought that was pessy doing a
joke voice no
I a water I honestly thought I'm not
kidding you that for a second pessy was
doing a joke voice oh no Daddy Daddy I
want but holy [__] H
[__] smell like poop hey don't you smell
like
poop talk to me oh good comic the insult
dog is your dad like that I like that
the actor was like look fine I don't
normally drink beer but I'll do MC Ultra
cuz you know I don't want to I don't
want to gain too much weight cuz you
could tell this guy is some kind of
actor that wants to be an actor he's
like look I don't normally drink beer so
if we're going to do a scene where I'm
an alcohol Ultra yeah no [__] no what
kind of alcoholic that's what I'm saying
no no [__] dope [__] rock bottom
[__] alcoholic is drinking that he'd
have a jug of plastic
vodka raise your voice at me raise your
voice I'm sorry get over here oh no do
you know how many times I have changed
my accent in this one
scene he was like Southern and now he's
Russian maybe he's from South
Russia it's
oh oh
oh you dir
slick cuz he's black yeah but here's the
thing right I don't think that
culturally Russians would identify black
people as slaves cuz it's not like they
had black they didn't really have like a
you know Russian black slave trade no so
like it's just funny that a Russian
would even think to go you're
slave he used to abuse me because of my
skin
color but but he married your black mom
yeah what that makes no sense wait he
married your black mom but didn't like
that she had a black kid yes he's all
part of the long con
baby and it's really hard to sleep at
night I know you have so many nightmares
no no cuz I sleep above a bowling alley
and Below another bowling alley wait
what sound ter bowling alley Avenue I
don't know why that why they built that
place it sounds ter rank control I guess
and there's a shooting range also right
next
door hey you should be happy it's not
summertime rooftop another bowling
Alle yeah I'm opening up an outdoor
24-hour shooting range I'm sure we'll
never get
complaints how how do you know I is
nightmares the time I slept over at your
house I woke up from all the screaming
that's bull I was in that room he didn't
scream
once uhoh are they
[__] why were you in that room don't
were they
[__] try to change the subject I had
a bartender I was [__] one time and
she she let it slip that we were [__]
and she was the one that [__] it up
because some one of the we're talking
about back when had the little fauxhawk
thing which by the way this give me give
me a break this was like 10 11 years ago
this is 10 11 minutes ago I had I had
the little fauxhawk going whatever and
somebody had commented on my hair and
then the bartender was like yeah it
doesn't matter I styles he wakes up and
it looks like that I was
like I was like everybody want to get
free drink everybody gets a free drink
let's forget about that that's the
closest thing you have in a bar to the
Men in Black thing free drink for
everybody you know what I can't take
this
anymore Kayla I've been sleeping with
Jackie oh wow he just came out with it
huh he put it out on FR that's how bad
he doesn't want to marry this old lady
[Music]
yeah are you being are you being
serious yeah no I'm just [__] with
you you
imagine bro I'm not a [__] could you
[__] imagine being in like a real
committed marriage and then just doing
that like as a [__] that be hilarious
we've been together for sometime and
then let it go on and be like no we're
just kidding I'm going to try that with
Maria I'm T you how it
goes it just backfires she's like okay
yeah wait what wait what yeah I always
knew you were gay wait
what me and Tom have been sleeping with
each other
[Music]
two questions number one why number two
who's the top Jack are you being
serious as serious as a $3 bill sister
so this guy's a Rob
Smith is that true how does it work with
women like with guys right if you find
out like you know if it's if you assume
right if I assume my chick's sleeping
with a chick or a dude then I'm gonna be
very upset but if they flipped it on you
with your guy you go oh wait so you two
have just been kind of scissoring and
[__] all hey nice BR no you should have
is exactly if it's two girls you're like
I don't care I just wish you would have
told me yeah I I mean can we see some of
it if we can see some of it butes how
does that work yo we're Gucci then I
don't care does that work with women
that way no CU I I think if you ask
women and correct me if I'm wrong women
well the women listen in the show are
broken but uh the I've had women tell me
that they don't mind seeing two girls
kiss but two guys kissing is gross to
them now I don't know that's true or not
true how does that work out you know
it's so funny man I've never really
gotten that like visceral grossed out
thing with gay guys like if they're kid
I always laugh like I my my go to was
always just and I started laughing I'm
like that's where they pass laws
here it's like I've never seen I guess
like when I see stuff that involves like
kids at the parades and stuff that
grosses me out or if they're really like
going at it right but if I see like two
guys holding hands and then they like
kiss and go in a play I'm always a I got
news for you that means you're gay that
means you're gay like I see like I've
always have that concern about dudes
that get really miserably angry and
you're like what are you doing bro like
I think that's really funny I like I
like the new the new like tra more tra
people nope neither are good not natural
let me tell you something maybe that's a
girl that's saying that but as a guy if
if you're going to [__] tell me that
you go through your search you've never
looked at any lesbian porn you're a
[__] liar you're lying and you know
you're lying listen e 1967 I I can
already tell by your birthday I don't
want to see you scissoring anyway so
keep keep your pants suit on it's fine
yeah yours are probably one of those old
rusted garden
shears [__] out of here you're probably
you're the wrong show this is not a
tradcon show okay we're the only funny
show on Rumble yeah me beat it you
probably look like Mrs kopel from The
Simpsons [__] [__] I've been
calling her crle but you know what at
least you have a really sexy name e
oh [__] I bet E's a real fun gal that go
C out the town red with well go I lean
on the pedal of your RV and get the [__]
out of here you Boomer you [__]
losers I'd rather [__] bet she was a
[__] smoke show in the 40s boys oh
God fing b b [__] saw the [__] black
and white Winston Flintstone cigarette
and when it first aired mhm seriously
speak yeah exactly I bet that's exactly
what she smokes Winston's hey e how is
the moon landing
yeah e listen I don't want I listen I if
I had a choice between eating your old
ass [__] or just going to hang out in
the Everglades in that pure in that 100%
pedophile Camp I know what I'd be doing
tonight
MH we're be playing pirates in a
treehouse what look was a good movie oh
[__] yes it's
true love you
oh my God look at the
photo solo
sea man that's really
gay lowkey in the chat says don't listen
to My Le no seriously don't listen to us
leave [__]
loser man those supplements didn't do
you chest any justice huh [__] look at
his chest that tits holy [__]
he's not in bad shape no but the
tits that ring was supposed to be for
me you were going to wear a ladies ring
I mean I get you're gay but you were
going to wear a ladi's ring and how are
you going to wrestle in on dark in that
oh come on man this and I was on a date
with Tom at the mall and you had to be
there to ruin
it is that an amber alert it's an amber
alert cuz they're all [__]
oh
okay guys I should probably tell you
about the kid we have locked
downstairs this is a live emergency
broadcast this is not a drill I repeat
this is not a drill gorillas from are
they going to do zombies yes gorillas
it's gorillas it's gorillas no no no
it's gorillas it's even better
gorill homophobic gorillas so I get this
I guess this took place during the
George Floyd riots
what's going
On's oh no they think I'm one of their
own I love this I love tomorrow's
teachings I love
them they just it goes it never goes
where you think it's going to go no
ever I like that they're just hopping
around lightly smacking the Airbnb to
it's also like they can't trash the
place they ripped the I don't like but
you know like if the gorillas were if a
gorilla broke into that place they'd be
ripping that fiber CH that fiberboard
[__] Furniture apart they'd be
smashing the place to bits but you can
tell they don't want to lose their
deposits so they're like no fake blood
either just rip an arm off
clean oh my God balance your audio Jesus
[__]
Christ hello humans my my name is Zula
leader of the new TR Clan I am the alpha
male we have been planning our escape
from the zoo for 55 years this is
[__] amazing so basically what
they're saying is a Mor of the story is
if you're gay gorillas were attack
you every single brother locked up in a
zoo enclosure has now can I play the
piano anymore of course you can well I
couldn't before breed we will run your
planet wow so you guys you guys have
been planning a a Revolt from the zoo
for 55 years mhm a group of animals that
live from 20 to 40 years yeah give or
take it was a generation well that's
because of heart disease oh the gorillas
okay that doesn't make a lot of
sense we own
you who's the slave now fine fine take
the casserole and go to try to alert the
authorities our brothers have over why
why they attacking just as one family
that's what I was going to say why
us like I would understand if it was the
White House or something you know
gorillas took over the State
House well at least now that they're
there people could start making super
chats
again we the gorillas have decided to
attack this Airbnb in
Fresno such a weird thing like why them
the gorillas orchestrated the greatest
Escape in yo that's from Planet of the a
that's footage from Planet of theory now
begin their Journey on ruling the
world does the human species survive
what does this have to do with gay sex
find out in part two I would IM imagine
I would imagine that because all right
so we have this thing these things
called
guns mhm so I would imagine that yes we
would probably beat back the Apes plus
there's only so many apes and if this
this revolution started in a zoo I would
imagine word probably didn't get out to
a lot of the wild Apes so I would
imagine it would probably get done PR
you guys don't have
smartphones